DR. RODGERS: Are you looking for online health
information you can trust?
Try the National Library of Medicine’s MedlinePlus
website!
Hi, I’m Dr. Griffin Rodgers, director of
the National Institute of Diabetes and Digestive
and Kidney Diseases at NIH.
My colleague, Dr. Patti Brennan, director
of the National Library of Medicine, or NLM, explains.
DR. BRENNAN: MedlinePlus is a website designed
by NLM for you, your family, and your friends.
It offers reliable, free, easy-to-understand
information covering more than one thousand
health and wellness topics.
With MedlinePlus, we have carefully brought
together evidence-based information from many
reliable sources – and it’s all in one
place.
For example, if you are looking for information
on a topic such as blood pressure medication,
you may also want resources about nutrition
and physical activity.
Learn more at medlineplus.gov and on social
media.
DR. RODGERS: For more information, follow us @NIDDKgov.
This is Dr. Griffin Rodgers.